I'm actually thinking Trump might lose
more and more really because it's it's
they are really really unleashing the
Beast and it's like every deals like
everyone's trying to steer this
narrative like every single thing that's
happened is Trump's fault everything not
even not even that but like all the
celebrities that are coming out and
every youtuber it's like everything is
just being lined up they are they are
firing every last thing they they have
yeah to go at Trump it's hard to know
man
I think I mean I kind of feel like no
matter what happens there's some kind of
civil war you know the number one search
term on Google today was Boogaloo really
Boogaloo Boogaloo yeah so I saw I think
was brian Stelter who tweeted like the
top search terms was like of the past
week was what do I do in the event of
martial law where should I go during
martial law what do I do in a civil war
and so I looked up Google search terms
in number one Boogaloo Wow more than
double the number two search term what
was that I think that the second one was
like Lafayette protests or something so
people are searching for Boogaloo yeah
think about how funny that is it's gonna
be like a hundred years and they're
gonna be like the second Civil War of
America for great Boogaloo
tell me more grandpa Bell why you what's
called Boogaloo well movie in the 80s
1980s and I have to explain everybody
the means think about like what is it
from Boogaloo I was it called was the
name of the movie it was something
electric Boogaloo everybody knows it oh
yeah google it electric Boogaloo I was
gonna say hit us up chat yeah yeah
that's gonna start screaming it soon
it's a it's a really crappy movie too is
like a b-movie that no one knew it like
break into break into a liberating - yep
and because because - and Boogaloo works
like everybody rolls with it you look it
up people already hit you know you know
it's funny about what's funny about this
is like I think back to like famous
quotes from founding fathers and and
people of great merit and they're very
like man you know the the quotes you
read are never like off-the-cuff slang
trash it's always well formulated it is
better that 100
person's escape and one innocent suffer
today if someone said that would be like
guilty people man they should be let out
cuz innocent you know they shouldn't be
hurt you know I'm saying like you know I
mean like quotes today right I was also
thinking about political correctness
would what affect quotes okay and I was
thinking like you can you can they
didn't say I think that should may have
said guilty persons but you look back at
history and it would say something like
you know never a man shall you know
fight without his spirit or some you
know some very noble statement and today
it's like we'd have to have all our
quotes are gonna be super PC you know
it's gonna be persons and any people so
like you know they they yeah oh dude
this is really funny like they're I
don't know if you saw the video it was
this like eighteen-year-old anti felt
left us to got arrested okay oh yeah I
don't know if you guys watch all this
and she's hyperventilating like like
freaking out and she's getting flex
cuffed and the cops laughing and they're
like okay her shirt said do crime it's a
be gay do crimes yeah went and did some
crime and you're getting arrested for it
so so III you know I did a segment about
this this morning and I I'm not trying
to be mean because look man kids are
kids when I watch a toddler fall over
and stub his knee and cry you know I
might laugh but it's not because I'm you
know trying to make the kid feel bad
it's because we get it you're a kid and
you're naive and young now you know the
best thing you got to do you got to go
yes you did it and they look and they're
like yeah and then they grow become
masochists they're like yes
no no but anyway somebody somebody
responded to me cuz I I commented like
the civil disobedience involves getting
arrested
mmm-hmm like any activist will tell you
if you want to go on protest you'll be
arrested don't worry about it yeah so I
could slap on the wrist it's like you as
soon as you get is like your conviction
okay it suspended sentence go home we
don't care you're done almost all the
activists get this thing I Fred what's
called where it's like okay as long as
you don't commit another commits a crime
nothing happens go home let me just walk
out yeah this kids freaking out somebody
responded to me using gender-neutral
pronouns and I'm
reading and I'm like what they said
makes no sense yeah because there's
multiple people there and multiple
people were asking for medicine and so
they were like you know they were
getting arrested because their stuff was
left and I'm like wait wait who the
stuff was here hold on hold on the
medicine belong to the other person bro
you got to use English man it's clearly
a female and like she like she'd even
tweeted and she didn't even have
pronouns or anything like we talking
about you now this guy is assuming her
pronouns are they or their Wow and I'm
you know I can see the backlash coming
but yeah so that's the anyway I'm just
imagining the the future how dare you
Tim well so how dare you think about
this is where we need the little Greta
button so we should pop up and then go
down I want it think about the future is
gonna be if this is what language is you
know you know man I'm sorry I just gotta
say is it's Boogaloo man you know why
yeah you know why cuz there's there's no
way for these two different disparate
worlds to exist coexist yeah they can
did you ever happen with the New York
Times we're talking about a little bit
house I'm actually I might get a phone
call I'm gonna cancel my New York Times
live if I come that would be hilarious
there we go you're getting a call is it
your time I don't know if as the New
York Times or not well how how would you
know anyway exactly it might say New
York Times I guess so they they ran an
op-ed from Tom cotton and saying send in
the troops and New York Times staffers
who are leftist revolted demanding they
take it down or whatever huh so the New
York Times apologized to their staffers
to everyone and now put writing an op-ed
for Tom for publishing Tomkins op-ed
saying send in the military I mean was
it was it far-fetched was it crazy was
it legit to be posting and I didn't read
it yeah I was fine it was like you know
here let me let me try and fix your
audio it said something to the effect of
we've we've got rioters running rampant
for the past few weeks the riding May
wet you know Wayne it may come back and
so let's get the American military on
the streets and the left was like Tom
Cotton's calling for Tiananmen Square
I'm like what are you talking about he's
calling for people to be sitting on a
street corner because
rioters are destroying everything yeah
dude it's been used before it's not it
and he specifically expa cific aliy in
the op-ed said we must pretty masculine
we must protect the peaceful protesters
yeah exactly or being you know these
riders and this is why I'm like you know
man after watching that arrest of that
little girl you know who was crying and
hyperventilating mm-hmm
I'm not super worried necessarily about
a civil war okay these people these
people are playing games like they don't
really know what's going on yeah they're
disrupting things and breaking
everything yeah I'm seeing that a lot
there's this you know what I was
thinking men so I've cancelled my New
York Times script subscription before
okay and then things kind of chilled out
a little bit they they made some hires I
thought was actually pretty good so like
okay other than your times again now I'm
just like nah that's it I'm cut it off
because now it's worse than ever now
it's like we are our cultural
institutions don't have the strength to
tell these whiny little pathetic babies
to shut them up yeah
just shut up they're all they're all
thinking they've been spoiled by movies
and video games thinking that they know
what life is about but that's just it
they've been stuck in video games yeah
you know they're living in that world
they think that that's how it works I
feel like your audios low for some
reason it's weird yeah that's what I was
saying everything out dude I've no idea
I was trying to we were trying to figure
skip a little closer and get a little
closer to the mic there you go that's
definitely better hello that's weird
maybe I'm closer than your can you hear
me now yes I can sir all right
demolition man its demolition man
demolition man yeah so I I'm you know I
think we have this obsession with safety
yeah and now you know we've had we've
talked about snow snowplow parents and
all this stuff at what point do you let
your kid fall down and just get hurt
yeah we need that
our skin has gotten thin it breaks so
easy they need a tourniquet you know
what's really sure I did there yeah yeah
so that so in that in that clip this is
this is really really funny um the one
the one girls getting arrested and then
her sister I guess is like I need my
insulin
I need my insulin give me my insolence
in my bag and the cops just like no now
she goes my blood Sugar's getting low
and I need my insulin and then right
away I'm like mmm when your blood
Sugar's low you don't take insulin yeah
yeah eat sugar yeah that will kill you
can go into a coma you need to be given
sugars alright so all these people are
all I'm looking at this tweet had a
million views dude this this little girl
getting arrested and and I'm looking at
all the responses on Twitter hmm and
people are like this is you know this is
obvious police brutality things like
that and I'm like if the if the cop gave
her that bag and she thought her blood
sugar was low and gave her and then she
injected insulin and she has died yeah
is that cut is it the cops fault
I mean not necessarily but the cops
probably like what you you want to
inject insulin when your blood sugar I'm
not gonna give you your bag yeah or you
might not know now here's the weather or
it could be in the bag well here's the
best part like when the other guy starts
yelling she needs her dialysis dialysis
I'm like what is obviously not oh my
goodness did I thank goodness I think
these people so so I tweeted an Tifa our
leftist in cells changed my mind I saw
that but I don't mean you caught some
eat for that did I
I so I got a note I got a notification
from Twitter saying like someone
reported the tweet and they found no
violation of the rules or German law
yeah somebody in Germany did it I'm like
oh yeah well it makes sense cuz Germany
isn't a chief a hotbed like all the poor
babies are mad that I made fun of them
but I don't mean in sell in the literal
term involuntary celibate mmm-hmm I mean
they're the left's equivalent of what
they call in cells mmm they are young
people who are homebodies who lack
social skills who are immature entitled
as yes sitting sitting and complaining
about the world because they lack
purpose and they can't solve their own
problems you know so that's what I'm
what I meant and it's true it's 100%
true but the problem is for our
societies when
you know on Reddit they have a subreddit
called insel tears okay and they just
mock and berate in cells from I read it
and I'm like that's a bullying subreddit
like I'm not cool with that if someone's
got a social problem I think we should
help them solve that problem agree the
issue is that the in cells aren't really
going out and doing anything
yeah they don't they don't want to I
mean they want girlfriends and stuff but
they're socially you know kind of messed
up if you're messed up and you're
sitting your baseman and you're messed
up about it I mean I think you need help
but as long as you're not hurting
anybody we don't me to complain about
right now the ante for people who are
socially messed up and believe insane
things are not being stopped are not
being mocked and actually if you mock
them you'll get banned so they're being
bolstered and this is this is what the
problem I have that girl getting
arrested basically was saying in the nor
in a normal world when she got arrested
people would laugh at her and she'd
toughen up and realize it wasn't that
bad
yeah instead she has everyone oh poor
baby a million views how dare they treat
her like this she's got a million views
she said that in a bus for three hours
in the new I know yeah that's it
the would have to go to jail you be sat
in a bus for three hours dude it's it's
it's more it's more painful to fly to
New Zealand like going on a trip to New
Zealand New Zealand
oh man sitting in for 12 hours and those
chairs man you know but you get to go to
New Zealand afterwards so but I know but
I mean like even going on a like Pacific
island vacation is harder than getting
arrested for a few hours
but she's getting reinforced by
everybody in on Twitter but she's also
getting a million views so you know what
she's gonna do again yeah do it again
I'm gonna get more why would I stop now
seriously I don't know I have a I have a
feeling that more than half of those
views were people laughing at her I hope
so
of course I mean I'm reading the
comments everybody's making fun of her
man yeah you know you know what's crazy
is that we used to have this this
culture growing up in school where
inside your school there was kind of
like a hierarchy in a sense they were
cliques
yeah yeah and I think each school is
kind of different because the schools I
went to didn't really have that but kind
of did
yeah certain groups who hung out
together and did specific things and
they knew who the popular kid was now
it's all just math on social media and
what happens is like I've explained
before it creates the opportunity for
political candidates like aoc who have
you know almost 7 million followers but
she clearly doesn't have that many
people in her district what she's doing
is she's highlighting the random fringe
extremists from all over the country
into a single place yeah where they can
quote you know come together online but
in the real world none of these people
form groups so that's what happens these
these kids in school who are normally
the weirdo loser kids that wouldn't get
any clout that wouldn't be praised are
finding a way to minute like get traffic
online and it's like warping their minds
to thinking they're right no no no it's
not even about thinking they're right
it's about thinking they're gaining
they're winning you know it feels good
I'm getting I'm winning it feels like
it's the same sure same thing so so you
have this 18 year old who's a weirdo
like I looked at her tick-tock and I'm
like just not you know not one of the
cool kids yeah
just kind of a weirdo but now after this
arrest and it's weird hyperventilating
I'm being brutalized help me help me now
her following is growing and all these
things what does that do it reinforces
that you did good people like this do
more so there's a mathematical
reinforcing of fringe ideologies but
more so just nonsensical behavior you
know we're in like the past who'd be
like you built a birdhouse high-five
buddy you know oh hey that was a tray
flip you know down that stair set that's
rad now it's like you got arrested
here's a million views ooh
go get arrested again yeah how much want
to bet she films another another her
getting arrested again because she wants
to recreate that moment where she got so
much praise hmm and following she's
going to put herself in positions she
even said it I'm going back to go you
know does she say she did she showed up
said I'll be coming back to the city the
police can't stop me so it's it's it's
unsurprising especially when you see
very very you know the internet creates
very very specific channels like the
hydraulic press that right out nickel
ball it's somebody who did a bunch of
things found success doing their thing
and that's normal that's like it's like
a normal good thing the problem is that
the Internet allows it allows you to get
good at things that make no sense and
don't help anybody so like we were
talking about the other day with mr.
beast mm-hmm
and he's uh he did you know he'd a bunch
of weird videos minecraft games and
stuff and then eventually found his you
know his thing giving money away which
is pretty cool art yes its regular old
reality TV they do these things all the
time they give out checks the Publishers
Clearing House so if you find that you
have success doing something normal like
culture commentary video gaming that
good for you but the internet also
allows people to do really weird things
like get arrested and then you end up
with shock prank channels where they run
around slapping people in the face and
then YouTube's got a ban those videos so
I think that's what we're end up seen
with a lot of these young people but its
political and then political ideologues
who want to weaponize that use it for
gain yeah encourage it so that's that's
where that's that's and I just something
I was thinking about thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you